oh this is a good one
jbm jean-baptiste
famous french international extremely
exciting
london system
which is characterized by the bishop one
f4 and
those three bonds in the center
c3 d4 and e3
and my opponent knows what he's doing
with uh quincy seven
uh yeah i don't know if this is great
i just thought of this idea one day what
what if i go dc5 and queen a4 in this
position
and then i thought i'll give it a try in
a serious game
at some point but apparently that
serious game is going to be
[Music]
this particular game against my french
opponent
which was not planned but that's okay
nobody watches these things anyway right
um okay e4
[Music]
probably bishop b5 could be a move
bishop c2 then maybe i want to push e5
it's taking a lot of time to think here
problem with d4
logical move is i take then uh
94 queen e4
and uh there's a double attack on
[Music]
on h7 and also on b7
and you could only protect one so i'm
going to take the other
bishop c6 queen b4 so i'm winning upon
at the expense
of my products pawn structure but i feel
like
the three one majority on the queen side
is gonna be
a huge factor even though um
i've got a pretty ugly
double pawn on on f3 and f2
so i could go before but i think that
just helps him
when he goes rook ach so i think i'll
just protect the pawn instead
maybe b5 was an option but a3 feels
safer
uh yeah knight e5 it's obviously a
pretty good move
uh it's it's a lot more annoying than i
thought
would like to play php2 with the rook
ac8 and i don't know what to do
so i'll go he need to instead not
thrilled about giving up the bishop for
the night but i think that's the only
way
not to allow him allowing any
immediate rook b8
the idea is clearly to go um
[Music]
to go a5 but it feels a bit slow
um
i'll go ruxy1
i think now and bhp4 is also interesting
bishop e4 you know i'll go bishop b4
since it seems all right uh regardless
of what i was doing the idea is always
to meet ab4 with a4
and i have lost the pawn but i've gained
an extremely
strong strong passport so now i go a4
maybe fc8 was was an option there
instead of
taking a b4 because now after
now after a4 i think i have a more or
less winning position
um i'm just pushing that
past pawn um i don't don't think there's
there's a lot you can do about it
yeah now the pun is just running
all the way being blockaded now
but my bishop is better than his knight
and also
i have a very dangerous pass pawn so
this should be plain sailing
rook c6 rook b6
collecting b4 then the other pawn starts
running
f4 just to prevent e5 key three
now knight b5
is fighting well
yeah rook b4 may actually not be so i'm
gonna give a check instead
rook c8
[Music]
96 i was expecting knight c7
okay 58 we push b4
and we went on time that's why i was
kind of relaxing at the end because i
knew i was winning that game on time
anyway
okay i was in it was an interesting
fight but it felt like
after i won that pawn uh although he
fought
he fought he fought well i felt like i
was always
quite a bit better